let me let me drag you back
to programming for a sec what three
maybe three to five programming
languages should people learn
do you think like if you look at
yourself what did you get the most out
of
from learning uh well so everybody
should learn
c and assembly we'll start with those
two right assembly
yeah if you can't code an assembly you
don't know what the computer's doing
you don't understand like you don't have
to be great in assembly but you have to
code in it and then like you have to
appreciate assembly in order to
appreciate all the great things c
gets you and then you have to code and
see in order to appreciate all the great
things python gets you
so i'll just say assembly c and python
we'll start with those three
the memory allocation of c and the
the the fact that so assemblies give you
a sense of just how many levels of
abstraction
you get to work on in modern day
programs yeah yeah graph coloring for
assignment register assignment and
compilers yeah like you know you gotta
do you know the compiler your computer
only has a certain number of registers
yeah you can have all the variables you
want a c
function you know so you get to start
your build intuition about
compilation like what a compiler gets
you
what else um well then there is then
there's kind of uh
so those are all very imperative
programming languages um
then there's two other paradigms for
programming that everybody should be
familiar with
i'm one of them is functional uh you
should learn haskell and take that all
the way through
learn a language with dependent types
like um
learn that whole space like the very pl
theory
heavy languages and haskell is your
favorite functional
what is that the go-to you'd say yeah
i'm not a great haskell programmer i
wrote a compiler and haskell once
there's another paradigm and actually
there's one more paradigm that i'll even
talk about
after that that i never used to talk
about when i would think about this but
the next paradigm is learn verilog or
vhdl
um understand this idea of all of the
instructions executed once
if i have a block in verilog and i write
stuff in it
it's not sequential they all execute it
once
and then like think like that that's how
hardware works
to be so i guess assembly doesn't quite
get you that uh something's more about
compilation
and verilog is more about the hardware
like get giving a sense of what actually
is the hardware is doing assembly c
python are straight like they sit right
on top of each other in fact
c is well let's see it's kind of coded
in c but you could imagine the first c
was coded in assembly and python is
actually coded in c
um so you know you can straight up go on
that
got it and then verilog gives you that's
that's brilliant
okay and then i think there's another
one now everyone
carpathy calls it programming 2.0 which
is learn
a i'm not even gonna don't learn
tensorflow learn pytorch
so machine learning we've got to come up
with a better term than programming 2.0
or
um but yeah it's a programming language
i wonder if it can be formalized a
little bit better which we feels like
we're in the early days
of what that actually entails
data-driven programming
data-driven programming yeah but it's so
fundamentally different as a paradigm
than the others uh like it almost
requires a different skill set
but you think it's still yeah
apply torch versus tensorflow pytorch
wins it's the fourth paradigm it's the
fourth paradigm that i've kind of seen
there's like this you know imperative
functional hardware i don't know a
better word for it
and then ml
you